braxton jake congratulations you fellas
have made it to the third round of this
competition now we're sending you back
to your home for just to make this
iconic weapon from history
[Music]
the
nagamaki good luck bladesmiths we'll see
you in four days
[Music]
it's day one i'm back at the home forge
i'm pretty nervous going to make my
first japanese sword
the first thing i do is taking it down
to size
[Music]
straightening this blade is a hassle
it's wanting to curve like a banana and
i'm having to straighten it out little
by little
i have to be very meticulous on the
amount of curve it has
it's the start of day two and i'm ready
to get to work and try and get this
blade quenched fire em up get em hot
i've never wielded anything that big and
i really just can't wait to test it i
can't wait to swing that thing around in
the yard just to have a feel for how it
is
i check the blade and it's hard it's
straight and i just have such a sense of
relief
let's hack it something see if it's
gonna break
just like that it snaps the tip off
about six inches down from the tip i
will not be able to meet parameters with
this blade so i decide to start a new
blade sign up a [ __ ] you know i
probably had a stress fracture the grain
in there is pretty tight
i got half a day left to hammer out and
forge out a blade
now that i've got the blade done we've
got the hibaki done and now it's time to
do the suba
the guard is very important everything
needs to be smooth oh that's a tight fit
feels really good it's just a little bit
heavy the nagamaki being too heavy can
make it unwieldable and make it
uncomfortable to swing around
right where the guard is it's a little
heavy
i mill a simple pattern into the sewer
to loosen weight
that actually
feels a lot better now
all i like is the wrapping and doing a
final cleanup i only have a few little
things to do on day four
this is cool
my last day i had so much to do i have
no room for error
i was able to
forge out a blade grind it out and get
it cleansed so
i'm just gonna try and meet the
parameters and get the blade turned in
and sharp that's pretty good
i have my hibaki done that took me a
long time yesterday i have my suba
pretty much where i want it
my main goal for today in general is
just to get the handle complete
i am quickly running out of time i
needed to make this handle as quickly
and efficiently as possible
i'm trying to get a pretty good grip to
where the blade is very easily indexed i
don't want the the handle be too thick
but honestly i just need to get a handle
on it
solid that's for sure
once the glue dries on the leather wrap
i go ahead and start this long process
of the ito wrap
this just so happens to be one of the
hardest builds i've ever done i really
could use an extra day but i'm just
happy that it's
over oh that is smooth all right blaze
missed i will take your weapons deliver
killing blows slashes and thrust on this
wild boar carcass
braxton of course you ready for this i'm
ready let's do this oh man we have hogs
around where i'm from skin is very very
thick i'm nervous but there's nothing i
can do
i just gotta let the chips fall where
they lay
[Music]
all right braxton
your nagamaki here is definitely not
boring
it is razor sharp every cut with this
thick wild boar carcass allowed me to
peel off layers of the very thick high
that it has also
the lightness that you have with this
blade allows for switching with the grip
here it's got very good grip in the
handle i can index exactly where the
edges at all times overall sir your
nagamaki
will kill
thank you
all right jake it's your turn ready for
this chop them up let's do this
it makes me a little bit nervous i
really want mine to chop through the
bore as well but the blade can actually
take a lot of damage during the boar
testing because there's bones
i know that braxton's blade is at a very
high bar mine needs to perform just as
good as his
all right jake let's talk about your
nagamaki here it's sharp
wielding this weapon is a lot of fun
also the weight you have here and the
balance works overall sir your nagamaki
will kill thank you
next up is the strength test dave
now to test the strength and overall
construction of your blades i'll be
chopping into this bamboo now this test
is not about what your blades do to the
bamboo what the bamboo does to your
blades braxton you're up first you ready
i'm ready
[Music]
uh
[Music]
all right braxton as far as what the
bamboo did to your blade it did nothing
uh there's no deflection rolls chips
anything on this blade it's it's as
sharp as when i picked it up nicely done
it's very strong blade thank you so much
all right jake you ready
let's do it
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
all right so your edge just as sharp as
when it started there are no chips rolls
deformation it
slice right through the bamboo
your handle is a little wide this way
for me but the fact that it's lean this
way and that that wraps so nice and
comfortable is uh it evens it out well
done thank you
all right bladesmiths we know your
blades can kill we know they're strong
now it's time to find out how sharp they
are now unlike the strength test this is
all about what your edge will do to
these different materials from the
tatami the melons or the sandbags
braxton you're first you ready for this
i'm ready
[Music]
all right braxton your edge had no
issues at all cutting through the tatami
mats cuts the melon easily and on
sandbags it will cut through overall sir
your weapon
it will cut
thank you
jake your turn you ready
do it
all right jade let's talk about your
nagi maki right here razor sharp it cuts
easily on the tatami cuts the melons and
just off the orders of the corners it
cut it easily
overall sir it will cut
thank you this is gonna be very hard for
us
bladesmiths the judges have made the
final decision
the new forged and fire champion is
[Music]
braxton congratulations you're the
forged fire champion jake unfortunately
your blade didn't make the cut ben
abbott's gonna tell you why well jake
you should be proud you made a beautiful
and effective weapon
and for us this came down to the finest
of points the fact that your blade
wasn't quite as finished and we had a
slight preference for braxton's handle
and that's the reason we're sending you
home jake please surrender your blade
i think the time frame that i had to
build my second blade definitely had a
factor in it i may not be the fortune
fire champion but i feel like i
accomplished a lot and
a privilege to be here
braxton congratulations you're the
forged and fire champion and that's the
title that comes with a check for 10
grand good job
i feel great about what i've
accomplished
i'm still shaking
it was awesome experience and i proved
that i can hang with the big guys
you